- [Jackie] Hi, welcome to the company.
Can I please have your I.D. for paperwork?
(phone rings)
- Do you mean this?
- I'm Jackie.
- I'm Ri Ching.
- Reaching.
- Ri Ching.
- Do you know what you'd like to order?
- I don't understand this menu.
- I recommend the chicken sliders.
- I'm a virgin.
- Wait, what?
- I don't eat meat.
- Oh.
You're a vegan.
- Who's you're friend?
- My name is Ri Ching.
- Witching.
- Ri Ching.
- Reaching!
- No.
- Do you have an American name?
- Where you from?
- China.
- Well, I know that.
Which city?
- Chongqing.
- Is that close Beijing?
- Yeah I just got back
from a trip to China.
- Oh yeah, which part?
- Singapore.
- Singapore is not part of China.
- Really?
There are a lot of Chinese people there.
- There are a lot of
Chinese around the world.
- How do you say bread in Mandarin?
- Mianbao.
- Me an bow.
- How do you say peanut butter?
- Huashengjiang.
- That's a toughie.
- My Chinese friend taught me this word.
Do you know what it means?
Chau di mau.
- It means have a nice day.
- Oh.
Chau di mau.
- No I'm just kidding.
It's a bad word.
It's a curse word.
- Oh.
- Do you know Alex Chen?
I went to school with
him, he's from China.
- Ri.
- [Both] Ri.
- [Both] Re.
- Oh, friend.
- Another iPhone 7.
God, I'm not your personal shopper.
- That is so cool.
- It's so cool you speak two languages.
I would love to be able to do that.
- I really wish that I could translate
from one language to another.
- Hey Raj.
- Hey.
- You know what?
- What?
- We're the cool kids.
- [Both] Reaching.
- Yeah! Very good.
- Yeah!
- Love it.
- Cool, I'll catch you 'round, Reaching.